[Music]
i started off in radio
from there i moved into television i
went to mtv
what was really interesting for me was
when i started at
mtv not only was i
one of the only uh working class people
there
i was to begin with the only person of
course
only woman of color there i come from a
tv
background so i use fashion analogies
but i look at gender
as almost wearing a coat that's just a
bit
too tight and it's just slightly
uncomfortable
you just know that there's a coat that's
a little bit more comfortable that would
fit
easier in terms of how you're treated
racism
i would say is coming into
a room in a jacket that is seen as the
completely wrong color there's nothing
wrong with the jacket you like it if
you think it's great but everybody else
reacts in such a hostile way to that
jacket that you're wearing is that
literally
how you feel yes and it feels very
differently that's why for me it's
really important to have an
intersectional conversation
because the way i'm treated
as a woman is very different to the way
i'm treated because i'm black they
feel very different and you know which
form of discrimination you're
experiencing because of the way it feels
yeah and i think it's really important
to make sure that others also understand
you would know more about this mean that
you've been studying gender
and reporting on gender for such a long
time and i think what's interesting
about the metoo movement and i'd love to
hear your opinion on it too
is of course it's a moment of reckoning
in that women are making sure that their
voices are heard
they are expressing painful uh emotions
that have been suppressed for so long
um and i think that you know like with
any shift if you look at the civil
rights movement it was similar in the
sense that
when we started really calling out this
level of injustice racial
injustice it was a real reckoning it
seems to me we've had this huge cultural
shift yes
which is great which has been terrific
yeah um but when it comes to actual
real economic financial and political
change what is that
i spent some time uh with alan smith
your data visualization editor
and i was shocked by the data that he
showed me
so alan you are our man in the know when
it comes to data
so on this axis here we're going to show
what is the gap so in the middle means
there's no
pay gap at all between men and women
in this direction is when you're paying
men more so at this level you're paying
men 50 percent more
than women that would be women being
paid 50 more
but what the data has shown us is that
actually over three quarters of
companies that did report paid men more
than women so these are all the
companies that are reporting a pay gap
in favor of men
and you can see that that's a sizable
number it's a big proportion and if what
really
completes this graphic obviously is do
you want to see the companies that are
paying women more do you
yes um there they are so
there is a huge difference and what
we're really looking at in this chart is
just the lack of symmetry yeah
and even the ones where we're getting to
the 50 mark that's still worrying
that's that's a big gap we spoke
with um i spoke with um anne pickering
from telefonica
o2 they have just managed i think as of
last year
their board is 50 50 which is wonderful
um but that was something that she said
was not easy
she literally had to be very clear
with her executive search firms to say
do not send me a list
that does not have 50 women 50 men
and wait for this some of them recuse
themselves
[Laughter]
so i found myself as the as the other i
was the only woman
in the room and much as my male
colleagues were a delight
i metaphorically i lost my voice so
that's when i realized how important
diversity was the penny dropped for me
at that point
so when the opportunity arose to recruit
additional people to the exact team
i would only work with a search firm
that would be happy recruiting a 50 50
gender balance shortlist right so you
stipulated that stipulated that
you'd be surprised june at the number of
search firms who were uncomfortable with
that request
so we didn't tend to work with them
going forward and
so for me it's all about creating a
level playing field and i don't believe
in quotas
so 50 50 gender balance shortlist and
then we chose the best person
who happened to be a female so it really
does bring diversity of thinking yeah
we're all very different
so much better quality of debate in the
boardroom much broader range of views
fantastic to have four role models for
the women in our business
and i make sure they get out there and
they talk to our female colleagues
that's really really important
we filmed the round table with uh
six key business leaders and they all
had different
views on how you actually create change
and how you make sure that it's long
lasting
and it was interesting because uh helena
morrissey
doesn't believe in quotas
even though the 30 club kind of is a
quota system isn't it that's
kind of the whole point of it but she
doesn't believe in quotas whereas
um sriti vadera and
karen blackett believe that you need to
have some sort of
clear metric you need to know what it is
that you're working towards
i think the easier task dare i say
it is women on boards definitely i think
the more difficult one
is senior women uh at the exec you know
executives
rather than at the non-executive level
which by the way is the source of the
pay gap yeah
the representation yeah and i think that
i
worry a little bit that the exclusivity
of the focus
on board level has actually also
taken women out of executive positions
into um going portfolio
possibly a little earlier and i think we
really need to focus on women
and um um
at the executive senior exactly and also
the
on the executive committees as well
which is the key yeah
he's not just a team not just a ceo or a
finance director who might be on the
board
yeah but in the in the levels below
because that's the talent pipeline
that's the future
yeah oh in our office something that we
we're always talking about is um
too much male energy
we have a sort of male energy measure in
our office
and that's because you know we've made
sure that the teams are equalized with
that thing but
but we we try to make sure that all the
teams that are working never become
one gender that's something that we've
been watching that actually when teams
start to aggregate into the same gender
even when there's diversity in it it
starts to produce a certain kind of
culture
and it actually affects the entire mood
of the entire office
something that's been really important
to us is how the micro
teams actually are organized starts to
dissolve that because then the kind of
bonding agendas
start to become much more soft
and they don't just become male
orientated or male interest only they
become soft and they become shared
and then that starts to have an effect
because then when you start to see the
kind of different team leaders winning
there's a kind of idea that it's not
about that one thing
you know and it's something we we can
tell with my leadership team
when we've hit the male energy meter
but like what just happened okay could
somebody do the numbers
oh my god we have more men in the office
commitments
do you think there's a fine line between
role model
and exceptionalism because
you know i was just pointing we'll know
that we've
kind of really got to success when
there's many mediocre correct
women in charge of companies
because it's so easy isn't it totally
good but i just wrote uh
something about this because um it's
interesting you know around
international women's day in particular
i often do start to feel
slightly exhausted but because one is
constantly being bombarded
with all of these stories about these
magnificent women who are indeed
magnificent
but it reinforces the idea that to get
ahead you have to be
so much nicer better brilliant more
generous more ethical more everything
and it's exhausting it's exhausting who
wants to keep
thinking about this you just want to get
on with it yeah
and you want to be mediocre if if
it's okay for the man to be mediocre why
can't we be mediocre too
now that is exactly what i said you know
we must fight for the right to be as
useless as anybody else
and this is the way the true equality
lies parental leave let's call it
parental leave
how we look at parental leave in the
first place in the round table this came
up a lot
and a lot of the mothers on the panel
talked about the problems that they had
had in their career
and i think one of the most significant
things we've done in o2 is we're in a
career returners program
how does that work so we brought women
back into the workplace
who've been out typically between two
and ten years
primarily having family bringing them
back on a 12-week course
and you know it's just all about giving
them the opportunity to develop their
self-confidence
you know i can remember it was many
years ago june when i had my children
um but you're off you know for months
and you really forget
about the world of work so giving women
the opportunity to come back
um as part of a cohort so they all join
at the same time
and giving them a mentor giving them a
coach
and allowing them to come back into the
workforce for around about 12 weeks
um to develop their self-confidence when
we started netapporte
the first i would say 10 employees were
actually dominant with mail
because we had id accounting cfo
that's kind of natural at this stage
quickly we start to get more and more
females in the company because it's a
female company the audience is female
my ism was okay having two people to
employ
a woman or male most of the employees
were young
so you deal with finding talents and
when you find talent you want to keep it
that talent female has to go in
maternity leave
and it's a huge challenge for a young
company when you find a talent
to actually find a replacement of that
talent and
after 10 years we were like a three and
a half thousand employees
two and a half thousand were women out
of these two and a half thousand women
you always have 50 60 pregnant women
and actually that kind of maternity
hub we had in the company was actually a
great way for us to find new talents
as when you grow a company number one
the woman being pregnant
most of the time and i see 95 percent
was coming back to the company so
effectively you don't lose your talent
but more importantly we had this like
hub of like
replacements who were there to support
for three months four months
we test them and actually they were
for us an amazing skill we had
they could be like one to replace
someone in the accounting
department actually she would go into
the magazine department
so effectively that created an amazing
asset it became a training program
almost totally and actually that ism for
me
really changed my vision on actually
hiring
young women it is actually an amazing
asset yes
i always talk about leave loudly so i'm
a single mum to an eight-year-old boy
and
fabulous thank you and i was promoted to
be
ceo of an operating company ten months
after having him
um and what was that like look i'm not
going to lie
it was something i'd always wanted but
my god i was thinking how am i going to
do this
but i set my stall out so had
conversations with my boss had
conversations with clients about
i am going to be more productive than i
ever have been
i'm just going to work in a different
way and i think again it's about that
conversation of normalizing this so
how have you designed how you work
because i think this is really important
particularly
for women in the world of work women who
are mothers
until we get to the place where men are
treated the same
in terms of paternity this is something
we really have to look at for women how
did you design that look i
talk about work-life blend rather than
work-life balance because work is life
and life is work and you've got to know
how to blend the two
and i am fortunate that i can have some
help with child care i'm out of the
office by six o'clock on the dot
i'm out the office and i'm gone and
there will be a blackout window between
six o'clock and eight o'clock where i'm
all focused on my son
and then after eight o'clock i will
answer emails but i think you know
the point about leaving loudly was
look i am putting my spikes on and lycra
to compete in my son's sports race
literally incredibly
but and i will and i'll say what i'm
doing because i think
when you try and not talk about it and
you try and hide it
it becomes something like a guilty
secret and it shouldn't be it's part of
your life
speaking of progression i mean one thing
that we are really looking at a lot is
promotion and um searching out for the
right candidates and just
thinking more broadly about that across
industries
this whole idea of building up a
pipeline is something that i know
people spend a lot of time thinking
about and to me
it just seems like a no-brainer i mean
of course you have to have a strong
pipeline yeah
of of women yeah you can really start to
paint this picture that there is
something happening to decelerate the
careers of women
so i'm gonna again look at the
proportion of women firstly what we
asked these organizations to report on
is by their kind of seniority so if we
look at the
junior staff in these same organizations
that we looked at just a minute ago
actually junior levels are far more
likely to be occupied by women yep
but then as you progress through the
company's organizational structures
at middle management there's already a
shift shift
it's it's straight away so there's some
because often
you know when you look at people that
report and work
uh in the space often they say it's the
middle area
is where the problem happens and that
women don't progress from the middle
to the sort of c-suite but actually your
data suggests it's actually happening
here
before we even get to them there is
clearly something happening
that's changing the gender structure
between uh junior and middle levels and
of course
you know you can guess if i'd ask you to
point on the screen where do you think
the senior level cluster is going to be
you know there's no surprise
all the way over there in the corner and
so i think what we're sort of seeing
here is again just more reinforcement
that there are some
you know the data is great at showing us
the symptoms if you like of
you know what's going on but i think
this is really important because
up until now the general thinking has
been that women get stuck
at the middle level and so for companies
wanting to address this problem
they're looking at the wrong place for
the problem this
is suggesting we need to start much
earlier in the company pipeline
and so setting out things like you know
the management of expectation
for career pathways right from those
junior levels incredibly important now
how companies react to this has been
extremely interesting to watch because i
think when with the first wave of gender
pay gap reporting there was a suspicion
that a lot of companies were waiting
till the very last moment
to report their pay gap data so that it
would get lost in an avalanche
of similarly bad papers so bad look at
them
um but there were a few companies that
took an exception to that approach one
of them was easyjet which did report a
very big gender pay yeah
but it reported it early on and made a
very big announcement
which was able to address it well they
effectively said a lot of our pilots who
are well paid
are male and we're going to introduce a
new recruitment program specifically for
recruiting
female pilots and so they took what
could have been interpreted as a very
negative press story about having a wide
uh
pay gap and came up with a solution that
i think
generated far more positivity for them
we've taken a big look at specifically
finance
um and i think finance is one where you
look at how does that compare to the pay
gap overall so we've still got the same
access here on this chart
yeah still looking at the pay gap this
time we're going to look at the
percentage
of companies that are payment in the
sector because they're all obviously
different
size industries and so on this line
shows us the chart that we were really
just looking at which is all companies
yeah okay so that's that
you know asymmetrical shape that we were
just looking at um
in finance there's far fewer companies
with
no pay gap the proportion of companies
with a with no pay gap is much smaller
yes and if you look at the proportion of
companies
um that are paying men more that's what
that looks like within
finance and what about paying women more
well
you're going to have to get your
magnifying glass out because there's
only a very few
um and none of these none of these
companies here are actually what you
would call big finance companies it
really is important to know
with this data what you can and can't do
so for example
we don't know how many employees there
are in any of these companies other than
the fact
that there's at least 250 there's at
least 250. and they can report companies
how
how many employees they have in an
overall ban but it's not comprehensive
enough
some of our colleagues here have linked
this data to
other data on the size of companies and
what it reveals is actually
about nine in ten women will work for a
company that pays men
more that's the figure it is that just
for finance or that's across the board
overall nine in ten nine and ten
um so it's really interesting this
because
when you put it like that it's even
worse than it seems
because because when we sort of round
the figure off you know we're sort of
saying 14
whatever the current figure is at the
moment but actually when you put it like
that
it's it just sounds terrible nine in ten
yeah
so without question the majority of
women in this country will work for
a business that pays men more absolutely
without doubt and this is the first time
that we've really been able to say that
based on an extensive
data set that gives us a snapshot of
that that's a reality
more women more diversity and finances
finance easy issue yeah i think that
finance is a big
issue yeah um i think that tech and
fintech and i feel
really bad about this because it's
almost like these are the startups
fintech is the kind of you know
blank sheet you don't have to have a
history of you know unconscious bias or
anything else
and then you have technology companies
that are worse worse
worse much worse there's an interesting
point here kind of paradox i don't
really understand
you could not find a business around
this table or more broadly
that wouldn't agree with the proposition
who is you what's your greatest asset
people
right so how much reporting
of your people characteristics goes on
not very much
i mean it shouldn't have taken the
government to come in
with legislation to require that to be
disclosed you know it's quite hard to
price what you can't manage what you
can't measure and well you can't measure
yeah
i think there's a lot further we can go
you're starting with gender which has
been a great start
through ethnicity and more broad and
disability and across the board and then
you've got a
vehicle for investors to begin to to
shine a spotlight on these things and
indeed regulators absolutely
that needs to be thought about and
reported and recorded not just
to your regulator but to your investor
which is why i was saying
the start that the important thing is
linking that measurement
at the team levels into
performance at the team levels because
at the end they're measuring their
performance because that's the thing
they're interested in
they've got to find the linkage at that
level yeah i think investors were very
slow off the mark around you know
flexing their muscles as it were
and partly because they felt
self-conscious that actually they didn't
look particularly diverse themselves and
now i think we've overcome that and
certainly legal in general has been
right out there in front and we've now
got within the 30 club an investor group
of almost 30
institutional houses and over 10
trillion pounds money that's a lot of
money we do get together
when companies are really um dragging
their feet and just even ignoring us
completely
i think it's been really interesting
just to look for example here in the uk
at the pay gap legislation for example
where for the first time it's really
quite groundbreaking
and i think a lot of people in britain
don't realize how people around the rest
of the world are quite amazed by that
and we're the only country doing it
properly actually
right and and so companies for the first
time have to actually
report their pay gap so that was really
exciting last year but then
this year it's so interesting the last
few weeks we've had you know the bbc did
this really interesting analysis i'm
sure
you saw it actually four out of ten
companies actually had a wider
pay gap not really where we were
expecting to go
and then it seems as though the
sanctions that people thought were going
to be imposed on companies that
right and so companies have been able to
report
figures that make no mathematical sense
and they haven't really been abiding by
the guidelines and nothing's happened so
that to me is a kind of a microcosm in a
way of where
we seem to be in a lot of areas yes and
i think that's actually
part of what needs to happen next with
the women's movement particularly in the
workplace
which is i think we have to get really
clear about what it is that we want
and what it is that we expect and then
demand it
in a really strategic way and a
systematic way
because when it's happening in isolation
when we're doing this in silos
you don't really have that sort of
systemic change that you need for this
to be something that's long lasting and
that's got to be the next phase of it
otherwise all it is is we're complaining
we're shouting
but we're not actually forcing change
we're speaking truth to power
but we're not changing the power right
right june you've spent the last couple
of months working
on this diversity series what's been the
big takeaway
number one just how beneficial it is for
the bottom line
and that actually companies need to see
this
as a way of future-proofing their
businesses and then the second part is
it's just the right thing to do
yes it's a smart thing to do but it's
also the right thing to do
and i think what i've been most
energized by is
the way that in the last couple of years
i've seen
a sort of a willingness at least an
openness where people are actually open
to at least having the conversation
and i think that in itself is a shift
you